the shaman wherever and whenever he or
she does their shaman izing the shaman
is a person who is able to transcend the
dimensional confines of cultural
existence the people they serve are like
children within the game of culture only
the shaman knows that culture is a game
everyone else takes it seriously that's
how he can do his magic you could always
tell the shaman because first of all he
usually didn't come out to see who was
there even though no one ever came even
though these people had visitors once
every six months the guy who wouldn't
come out of his Hut for the only event
in six months was inevitably the shaman
and then you met him he wasn't
interested in your velcro or your or
your break the part below in the dark a
little trinkets or any of the rest of it
it is looking straight at you through
the eyes outside the culture then what
kind of a person are you are you a fool
or are you a clever fellow
what is your measure how much of the
situation do you understand how many
levels are used simultaneously of
at this moment and you know looking into
the eyes of that sort of person you
either go or turn away